ليس خفيا انه منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
كانت هناك زياده ملحوظه في الانفاق
الدفاعي حول العالم خاصه لدى الدول
الاوروبيه التي تزايدت مخاوفها من
التهديدات الروسيه وفي نفس الوقت ايضا
رفعت التدريبات العسكريه الصينيه والكوريه
الشماليه من مستوى المخاوف ما دفع الدول
المجاوره لبكين هي الاخرى الى رفع
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لكن السؤال ما هي
تداعيات هذا الارتفاع العالمي في الانفاق
على التسلح على الشركات الدفاعيه خاصه في
ظل موجه من التضخم العالميه التي يعاني
منها العديد من الاقتصادات حول العالم
وكذلك ايضا على الامن العالميه حول هذا
الموضوع معنا من لندن المتخصصه في
الاقتصاد الدفاعي في المركز الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه السيده فينيلا اولا
السيده في اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتانيا على
مدى العام الماضي الكثير من الدول اعلنت
عن زياده ميزانيتها العسكريه لكن برايك هل
ست لتزم هذه الدول ام انه الامر لن يتعدى
مجرد خطابات سياسيه واعلاميه لا اكثر
شكرا على الاستضافه شاهدنا موجه من
الاعلانات من الدول في انحاء اوروبا بشكل
اساسي في اعقاب الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
فبراير الماضي تفاوتت فيما بينها من حيث
سرعتها وشدتها لكن الاتجاه العام كان
واضحا نحو رفع الانفاق على الدفاع
بالمقارنه مع اجمالي الناتج القومي واتت
هذه الاعلانات في اوروبا رغم التحديات
الاقتصاديه المتزايده فقد كان عام 2022 هو
العام الثامنه على التوالي لزياده الانفاق
الدفاعي في اوروبا والان تراجع المعدل
بسبب التضخم حاليا من الجيد ان نرى
استمرار هذا النمو في ظل الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا الذي حفز رفع الانفاق على
الدفاع لكنه كذلك عطل واضر الاقتصاد
الاوروبي بشكل كبير مما ادى الى التضارب
بين اولويات الانفاق العام بالنسبه لصناع
السياسات